now that you've been in the business a
while you've also worked at CAA I
believe in innovative how has that
helped show you maybe that it's not so
rosy that you can't just come here and
and and it does take time he talked
about building a career brick by brick
it's not this overnight thing but how
has that helped you so that it does you
said there really is no balance but in
seeing that there is really no kind of
straight ride to the top how does that
help to use well you know I I went to
film school as well i was at UC santa
barbara the film school there is theory
and history based so I an emphasis in
screenwriting production so I tried to
get an overall education of filmmaking
as a whole but it was a great foundation
because I learned a lot about history
and about the theory you know of
filmmaking so I when I graduated and I
moved to Los Angeles sure i thought i
was going to conquer the world i thought
you know i wasn't gonna be like everyone
else said that i could make it to the
top relatively unscathed and climb that
ladder quickly but you quickly learn
that that's just not the case we all
have to work incredibly hard we have to
pay our dues we have to make our
connections it's rare that you are just
born into it or given that golden ticket
so for me it was a kind of a unique
situation one of the first jobs that i
had in los angeles was working in the
lit Department at innovative artists and
I was working under an agent Nancy my
Grosh who was although there are no
titles she was technically the head of
the lit Department she had incredible
clients I learned so much I was doing
coverage on a daily basis I probably
read close to 500 scripts if not more
and I learned the business of what it
was to you know help represent a writer
help get a project sold and even just
the bare bones of what it was to write a
script you know because I was constantly
constantly reading them so having
started there it got me excited about
screenwriting and it
made me want to pursue my own career and
I was after a few years they're ready to
leave and pursue that and I had some
friends who were over a creative artists
agency and they convinced me to go over
there and work for a while and I was
planning on moving over there to be on a
lit desk because I preferred the lit
side of the agency but I was actually
asked to work for Joel lubin who is
motion picture talent he is incredible
an incredible agent represents some of
the best actors in town I mean his
client list is is Zac Efron and Tom
Cruise and you know Ashton Kutcher among
others so I also learned that side of
the business that the talent side of it
and made a lot of great connections so
based on those two different
opportunities once I left creative
artists agency and started my own career
writing I knew a little bit more about
what it took to write a script and to
create something that was both creative
that I believed and it had an integrity
to a story but also that had a certain
marketability in mind so I think that I
as I told you before sure we have these
peaks of megalomania and these valleys
of self-loathing but I think if you can
prepare yourself for what the actual
industry is and and and prepare yourself
for what you have to do to to get there
and know that there's going to be a lot
of failure and rejection along the way
then you know you can deal with a little
bit more of those hardships you know cuz
it's it's a bit of a cliché now but you
know you hear from people in all
different types of work within the
industry that there's nothing really
glamorous about the industry you know
it's it's it's a business like anything
else it's very difficult it's very hard
and you have to put in your time and
effort so I think that you you can get
past those days of self-loathing knowing
that you're
time and effort to get there where you
need to be and so you know like I said
you caught me on a good day I guess
because I have a lot of great projects
that I'm excited about and you know I've
had a lot of great writing as of late
you